[Musique]
tu sais l'été c'est juste vijnana pitié
arrête la
dépression gee un normalement censé
prendre un verre avant ouais avec le
bateau à pleine capacité ça te montre le
gars le plus mobile que j'étais je me souviens que je
jouais avec des cailloux jetant n'importe quoi sur le
sol  et je veux dire imaginez qu'ils se
battaient imaginez moi je pourrais voler bientôt je me suis rendu
compte que les super
super héros existent dans la vraie vie je n'avais
que quatre ans quand les talibans sont arrivés à
Kaboul et ma famille a été forcée de déménager
De l'Afghanistan au Pakistan pour s'assurer
que notre famille gagnait la sécurité, mon frère,
elle a donné à ma sœur piscina swad et
moi-même, maman et papa, devons
tout recommencer à zéro et le Pakistan pour
s'assurer que tout allait bien, leur
motivation était notre sécurité, nous sommes restés au
Pakistan pour un  quelques années et puis nous avons
déménagé en Russie dont un nouveau membre
de ma famille a été autorisé avec l'aide
de mes oncles nous avons pu déménager en
Russie Mike ma boussole a agi comme des
super héros
le  j'ai vécu en Allemagne mais leurs super
pouvoirs de compassion surpassent l'espace de Simon que
nous avons après notre séjour en Russie nous avons
déménagé donc à l'âge de 10 ans j'ai déménagé pour
beaucoup partager avec toute ma famille en
Russie j'ai dû apprendre à apprendre le russe
et j'ai travaillé  avec mon père
un grand marché aux puces quand je suis arrivé à
Montréal j'imaginais que cela ressemblait à l'
avenir pour moi quelqu'un qui venait de
ce n'est pas le Pakistan La Russie quand je suis
arrivé au Pakistan Oh comme je l'ai dit j'ai été
inspiré par mon père qui a travaillé très
dur pour  assurez-vous que nous avions de la nourriture sur
la table
nous sommes arrivés à 1sheeld en 1997 quand j'avais
10 ans, y compris mon nouveau membre de la famille
étudié quand je suis arrivé à Xi'an tout ce que j'ai
vu, c'est que je pense que c'est compatible
démissionner et à la division maman et  nommé
pour faire notre devoir beaucoup plus ne l'imaginez
pas une coquille découpée ouais vivo
kannada si un fossilisé spécifiquement
parce qu'il peut assister à son
infra actuellement dit si je disais celui-ci sur l'
état et sa misérable nourriture de méditation
j'ai eu de la chance parce que thro  Pendant mon
enfance, j'ai embauché et découvert que le
rôle secret était ma mère, elle m'a appris à être
une bonne personne, un bon musulman, elle
m'a appris que peu importe d'où venez-vous d'
Anna, d'où venez-vous d'où une famille que
nous sommes ici pour aimer donner  et prenez soin les
uns des autres, elle m'a également appris que les
musulmans étaient des super-héros, le Saint
Prophète Mohammed enseignant sur l'unité et
la justice sociale. Il écrit également sur
l'importance de l'insuline.
loi
ma mère m'a appris qu'il y a
des êtres spirituels et il y a cette
belle citation du jeune phénoménal
Shaolin qui dit que nous ne sommes pas des êtres humains
ayant une expérience spirituelle
nous sommes des êtres spirituels ayant une
expérience humaine nous sommes Stardust nous sommes
supérieurs ma foi en l'islam m'enseigne  pour
être socialement conscients que nous sommes tous
responsables les uns des autres et que nous
devons nous assurer de travailler ensemble comme une
seule race humaine,
nous avons juste besoin d'écouter et de regarder le
monde à travers les yeux de notre cœur pour
s'assurer de faire de ce
monde un meilleur endroit nous sommes tous des
super-héros et découverte je me rends compte que les
super-héros ont des super pouvoirs nous sommes tous
notre club de superpuissance la compassion l'amour l'
unité sont des qualités que nous ressentons au
cœur  de qui nous sommes aujourd'hui,
je comprends que les super-héros ont tendance à
faire du divin dans les moments de difficultés,
mais le plus important, ils sont reconnaissants
d'avoir des moments de joie et d'être
inspirés par eux, j'ai réalisé que les
super-héros ne se battent pas les uns contre les
autres, ils se battent ensemble pour  la paix pour l'
unité pour la justice au profit des
gens, quelle que soit leur religion, leur race, leur
sexe, leur orientation socio
-économique ou la couleur de leur peau, ils sont en fait
intellectuellement généreux, ils sont des
citoyens du monde, ils viennent des
stars et de l'univers, ce sont toujours des
enfants des enfants qui  imaginez imaginez cela signifie
qu'ils deviennent ce qu'ils imaginaient mon nom
est Mike j'ai 31 ans je suis un musulman un
canadien un être dans le  univers
et j'étais super vue et croyez-moi les
super-héros existent
vous